souvent c'était en fin de soirée on se
dit ok peut-être qu'on pourrait faire
une ferme tous ensemble en plus on
s'entend bien on aime bien faire la fête
ensemble donc on est une forme un peu
particulière parce que on est aux
paysans à travailler il ya vivre ici
donc on produit du pain de la bière du
fromage de chèvre du fromage de vache la
viande de porc et des légumes
il ya également un atelier
d'architecturé et on travaille en
agriculture paysanne et je vais vous
montrer comment ça marche
[Musique]
là sur four mais le pain que j'ai fait
pas mal ce matin et qui sera vendu ce
soit à notre magasin à dakar et qui
n'est pas loin avec du blé convaincu
petit sur la ferme ou à la ferme et que
que je planifie t'aide à te rends
collectif ça permet quand même de se
libérer du temps donc nous on essaie de
sortir quatre semaines et demie pour
cinq semaines de vacances par an et
quand alexis par exemple était en
vacances c'est moi qui le remplace sur
le pain qu'on en fait l'atelier pain et
les hyper intéressant parce qu'il est
demandé très peu de travail est assez
rentable par rapport à ça mais on va se
sortir un salaire
donc on se sort le smic là depuis un
depuis un an quoi donc c'était un peu
notre objectif on s'était fixé un peu
cette rémunération parce que je
considère que voilà c'est une
rémunération convenable
je m'appelle charline et là on va aller
chercher les vaches pour la traite
j'occupe mon temps à moitié entre les
vaches laitières et le maraîchage en
choisissant limousin c'est vrai qu'il ya
une paris à une grande partie des terres
qui sont difficilement cultivables du
coup c'est vrai que les animaux ils ont
toute leur place notamment dans ces
endroits là
alors après je pense je crois qu'elle
est elle le connaître ses intentions en
tout cas le boulot d'éleveurs laitiers
notamment qu'il ya une astreinte
quotidienne qui est assez importante
avec la traite nourrir les animaux etc
nous on fonctionne avec un système
d'astreinte du week-end donc il ya une
personne qui gère toute la ferme chaque
week-end
donc en gros on travaille un week-end
sur 11 du coup ça permet d'avoir
le week-end de libre quoi se libérer du
temps c'était ça faisait partie de nos
objectifs de départ à l'installation
chose que laquelle on arrive tu avais
fait sonner les mots avant de très
content il est pas beau il ya des
grumeaux ou alors il est un peu a que
deux trains devraient se rendre à avully
aujourd'hui il faut savoir qu'il ya
quand même toute la génération du baby
boom qui va partir à la retraite vue qui
a pas de repreneur en grande partie
elles vont être reprises à
l'agrandissement quoi donc ça veut dire
qu'il va les fermes pour en devenir de
plus en plus gros de plus en plus grosse
et les pratiques vont forcément
s'industrialiser d'une urgence absolue à
ce que les gens de les jeunes ou les
moins jeunes défilent viennent en
campagne pour faire de l'agriculture
quoi en fait on et certifiées en
agriculture biologique
mais on se revendique plus de
l'agriculture paysanne tu veux un coup
de main josé et ben ouais carrément le
but de l'agriculture paysanne c'est de
de produire des aliments sains en
faisant attention à l'environnement et
en faisant attention aux paysans quoi je
suis là depuis quatre ans et demi donc
j'ai partie les personnes qui ont
imaginé le projet l'aspect collectif il
est très très important pour moi presque
au delà de
de l'aspect agricole voilà puis la tp
sera le fait qu'il ait une cohérence
dans tout ce qu'on fait entre le monde
qu'on imagine dans sa globalité et puis
en fait nos actions qui font que on a
l'impression de proposer un modèle où
nous on se sent bien
weng weng
ici comme tous les mardis et vendredis
c'est le magasin à la ferme on vend nos
produits mais aussi un bar pour servir
de la bière pour nos clients ça fait
vingt 3,95 sur tout pendant l'été il ya
une petite programmation culturelle
chaque année on fait on envisage à peu
près une dizaine d'événements ou qui a
des concerts des spectacles
on n'avait pas envie d'être un de vivre
dans une sorte de communauté autarcie
pour valider des de la ferme c'est que
ce soit voilà c'est de proposer à la
fois un autre modèle agricole mais aussi
de proposer un lieu de rencontre à la au
bout de deux de quatre ans et demi on
est vraiment contents du résultat dans
le sens où
nos objectifs de produire dans une
agriculture qui répondent à nos
convictions se libérer du temps libre se
rémunérer correct correctement ces
objectifs sont atteints et du coup on se
sent aussi de montrer un peu plus qu on
fait quoi